so this is kind of anti-climactic but
sort of kind of cool at the very end so
a newborn giraffe gets attacked by a
lion i'll play the video for you and
it's miraculously survives right well
they have to walk right away obviously
because [ __ ] everything's trying to
kill him oh [ __ ] so you'll see it here
okay
how [ __ ] up is nature nature i know so
fault there he goes oh [ __ ]
it killed my chin no we'll see you watch
here
let me fast forward so he has him there
i got his head wait that baby draft
survives this so leaves him alone there
he's playing possible watch watch
drags it again all the way over here
look how many cars like land rovers out
there yeah more mama drafts like what
are you guys watching so it's right
there just laying down that's a krueger
knife where's the mom kick him in the
[ __ ] snout i know it's tough that's a
lie so then she's trying to yeah shoot
him away so it's just sitting there then
he gets up it's watching
yeah i don't think he's okay though i
think no he's playing blossom does yeah
so he gets back up baptism by fire ain't
it
wow
so what happens afterwards
is he walks into
the lake or the pond oh that's not good
an alligator it's not okay crocodile he
drowns
he drags that's how he dies absolutely
he was enabled he was able to survive
the lion attack no he wasn't and then it
just peacefully drowns himself
no
i know that was a plot that's what i'm
saying it's like a climactic
anticlimactic the best way to end this
podcast i've ever heard that's a [ __ ]
oh man right that's right like i just
did he goes for a little bit mom
hey mom let me cool off for a second let
me get in the water
he's not doing it where's the crocodiles
man that's crocodile food
yeah yeah that's not a good time he's
probably okay mom i'm just gonna cool
off for a second here give me give me a
few minutes cycle love love there it
goes
that was the end of it that's it yeah
well that's what happened that's how he
died that's how he died drowning
getting ass first by lying you're
[ __ ] first minute out of the [ __ ]
wounds
yeah
god nature's a [ __ ]